I made my Korean acting debut.
I'm about to shoot a scene for a soap opera
that's very popular here in South Korea.
They asked me to use my face for green screen, via fish.
I really don't know what's happening.
But hey, you!
Why don't you?
That's you!
Jang Nara is a big star.
Not just in Korea, but all over.
My co-star.
She's gonna fall in love with me,
as every actress I've ever worked with
falls in love with me.
And it's just gonna happen.
(man speaks Korean)
Action!
(beep)
(Nara speaks Korean)
(man offscreen speaks Korean)
(beep)
Nuh-rang ssum-tal-soo up-ja-na.
(audience laughs)
Nuh-rang.
Oh, nuh-rang.
(beep)
Nuh-rang up.
(audience laughs)
(beep)
What's that?
Want me to do it a few in a row?
Ya-gi kai-pun-yun.
(man offscreen speaks Korean)
Huh?
(beep)
Ga-gi.
Kai.
Ha-myun. Ha-myun.
Ha-myun, I see.
(beep)
Ya-gi kai ...
Ha-myun.
Ha-nyum.
(audience laughs)
Ha-myun.
Okay.
Ya-gi.
(beep)
(Conan and others laugh)
Na-mwal hal-a-gu-yao.
Bung-a-yah.
(audience laughs)
Nol.
Okay.
Here we go, nol.
(beep)
Nol-mwal-ha-la-heen-yao.
Bung-a-yah.
(audience laughs)
Nol.
(beep)
It's you.
Nol-mwal-ha-la-mu-yao.
(audience laughs)
I am glad to meet you.
And hopefully you can find soulmate here.
(blissful, twinkling music)
Your name is?
Conan O'Brien.
(Nara speaks Korean)
(blissful, twinkling music)
I'm looking for a woman who's five foot seven.
Big, beautiful eyes.
Petite.
A woman with a history.
It's you.
(Conan speaks Korean)
I won't join your marriage service group.
What? Why?
(Conan speaks Korean)
I wanted to really tell you sincerely.
Love overcomes everything.
(Conan speaks Korean)
(audience cheers)